Now let's get to solving the problem and coding it up.
But before I do that, I want to introduce one more piece of jargon,
which is if I'm at a particular state, and I decide that that's the endpoint
of the path that I want to expand, and I come up with the states you can get to from there
by expanding the path and the steps that it takes to get to those states.
I call that the successors to this state.
The successors are a collection of states that you can reach\
and the steps that it took to get there.
Here is my solution. It's a little bit complicated. Let's go through it step-by-step.
I'm saying the input to this pour problem function are X and Y,
which are the capacity of the glass for that.
Then the goal, which is going to be an integer, like 6, to say that's how much I'm trying to get to.
That can be in either one of the glasses.
Then the start state, which I'm defaulting to 0 and 0, saying both glasses have current level 0,
but if you wanted you could generalize the problem and pass in something else as what we're starting with.
I'm using lowercase x and lowercase y to indicate the current capacity of the glasses.
Here I check and see are we done before we even get going?
Did you give me a start state and say the goal is the have a glass with zero in it?
Then we're done before doing any actions.
Go ahead and return that.
What I'm going to return is called a "path."
The path is a alteration of states and an arrow, which will give a name to each action,
and then the other states that it goes to, and we alternate out with the states action states and so on.
Here, if there's nothing to do, it's just a state with no actions.
We're going to keep track of the states that we've already explored
and that's going to be a set.
We're going to keep track of the frontier.
Conceptually, that's a set too, but we're going to pull the items off of the frontier one at a time,
so I've made it an ordered list rather than a set.
I know which element of the frontier I want to explore first.
So the explored is a set of states, and a frontier is an ordered list of paths.
The only path we have so far is the trivial path that says we're starting at the start,
and we haven't gone anywhere else yet.
That's what we start our frontier with.
While the frontier is left, while there is still frontier states that we haven't explored from yet,
we pop off the first one.
Pop(0) says take the 0th element of the list, so we're going to pull elements off
of the front of the list and push them onto the end of the list.
Then say the current state is the last element of the path,
so the path goes from one state to the next, and the last element of the path is the current state.
Let's take x and y from there.
Then I've defined a successor function that gives me all the successor states
and the actions we used to get from there.
There should be six of those.
Then if we say if that new state is not explored then it's something new.
If it was explored, there is nothing left to do.
We're already explored from there.
If it hasn't been explored yet, then add it to the explored set, make up a new path,
which consists of the old path plus we follow an action to get to the new state.
If the goal number is somewhere in that state, so the goal is 6
and the state is the two levels of the glasses, say 6 and 3, yes, 6 is in 6 and 3.
Then we're done. Return that path as the winner, the path that reached the goal.
Otherwise, just add this path onto the frontier, and we'll pull something off the frontier later.
If we go all the way through and we run out of frontiers to explore from,
then we can't reach the goal and we return fail.
You could have Fail be None.
I decided to make it the empty list, because all the other things we're returning were lists.
Either way, None or Fail, both are equivalent to False in Python if statements.
So probably either one would do fine.
Here's my successor function.
It takes the current levels of the glasses and the maximum capacity of the glasses.
What it's going to return is a dictionary of state-action pairs.
The state is just an x-y pair of what the levels of the glasses are going to be,
and the action is how you got there.
We're just going to use strings to represent those actions,
so it's just something that we can print out
that is otherwise unimportant in the operation of the program.
First I wanted to check that this is a legal state that the fill level of x is less than its capacity
and the same for y.
Then I said here are the six possibilities.
The pouring is complicated. Let's do the filling first.
The filling says you can fill X up to its capacity--capital X.
You can fill Y up to its capacity--capital Y.
You can empty X. That'll become 0.
You can empty Y. It will become 0.
Then the fill--there are two cases.
If the total amount of water is less than y, then you can take all the water in the first glass,
which is x, and add it into y, so you get y plus x.
Same thing in the other direction.
But if the total amount of water is more than the destination that you're trying to pour it into,
then you could only pour as much as will fill up the other glass.
We can see that there is conservation of water here.
The total amount is x + y minus this difference plus this difference.
I got the definition of my program pretty much just by following out the implications of this diagram.
We're going to keep track of an explored set, never try to return there,
expand the frontier, pop off one element of the frontier,
add in the new elements, and check when we get to the goal.
Then that was all kind of generic for any exploration problem.
Then for the specific water problem, the successor function and the way that was laid out
was specific to what we're doing with the glasses.